[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Слобожанщина,
Суми]
Скульптор — це публічна людина, як політик.
Він повинен бути як камертон для суспільства.
[Леонтій Костур-Шаргородський
Художник, скульптор]
Чому? Тому що скульптура — вона ніби вічна.
Це має велике значення для суспільства,
скульптура.
У виховному плані і в мистецтві.
У художні музеї рідко хто ходить, так?
Це погано.
Але скульптуру бачать кожен день.
Від того, яка якість скульптури,
така якість і громадян.
Ну, до мене заходять, кажуть, що...
Є люди, які не розуміють мистецтва.
То вони кажуть: «Та,
ми не розуміємо, що тут зображено,
але відчуваємо цей дух».
Я народився у Вінницькій області.
Є такий районний центр Шаргород.
І це...
Місто, воно дало мені і сюжети,
і психологічне забарвлення робіт.
Часто ми ходили на базар там,
бачили різноманітну таку культуру:
єврейську, польську, українську.
І це досі є для мене
основою творчості.
В якому би матеріалі я не працював —
я бачу цей Шаргород.
Глина дає можливість
виражати те, що ти думаєш, — напряму.
Вона така гнучка,
що ти можеш її ліпити що завгодно з неї.
Будь-яку думку.
І передавати вираз,
щоб воно мало індивідуальний вигляд,
ця скульптура.
Мені це приємно — працювати з глиною.
Після глини
я став займатися деревом.
Дерева тут валять або вони самі падають,
і приходиться деколи
якісь комеля там прибирати,
і з них робити роботу.
Випадково став скульптором.
Я ніколи про це не думав.
Коли переїхав сюди в Суми,
то я кинув малювати, ось, і зайнявся бізнесом.
Років 15 я займався бізнесом, а потім
так вийшло, що стало нецікаво.
І я просто будував цей будинок
на залишки тих грошей,
що в мене залишилися.
Як якось працював тут,
щось робив у дворі,
під'їжджають сюди на Волзі
двоє чоловіків і кажуть:
«Ми б хотіли, щоб ви були директором заводу».
Виробництво сувенірів, кераміка.
Я кажу: «Та, я ж ніколи на такому
підприємстві не працював».
«Будинок ти будував?»
«Ну та, я. По своєму проєкту. Ну та».
«Ну значить впораєшся».
Ну я почав робити оці перші роботи,
просто так заради того, щоб не сидіти.
Після того я став працювати
з глиною, бо вже звик до цього —
і так я став скульптором.
Ну в якому стилі може Костур працювати?
Ну в стилі «костуризм».
Ну це стиль
індивідуальний.
Тобто це не є там як кубізм, припустимо.
Костуризм полягає в тому,
що проявляється людина як індивідуум.
Оце музей — він зареєстрований уже з 2006 року.
Ну приїжджають, і з Гарварда приїжджають,
і приїжджають із Парижа, їдуть.
Не дуже часто, ну так,
три-чотири екскурсії,
родини на рік.
Я думаю, що у нас скульпторів,
припустимо, не менше,
ніж в деяких розвинутих країнах Європи.
І може, вони не гірші.
Але наша Україна така велика,
ми не спілкуємося одне з одним.
Ми не знаємо, фактично, нашу силу.
Ми не видаємо ніякого журналу.
Таких, щоб можна було щось
духовно
об'єднатися ,— такого немає.
Мене кличуть
і в Америку,
і в Австрію.
Тобто я міг би  реально там
десь причепитися до чогось, але...
Для людини, яка поважає свій рід,
неможливо змінитися ніде.
Інша річ, що є багато людей,
які не поважають свій рід.
Вони змінюються відносно до того,
де вони перебувають.
Вони такі — фарбуються в таку фарбу.
А людина, яка поважає свою націю,
поважає свій рід,
вона не змінюється.
Тож це воно вже, як прилипає, то навічно.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Олег Сологуб, Олексій Панченко]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Tik Tu, Sasha Boole]
[Cубтитрувальниця
Валерія Діденко]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]